it is seven o'clock great to have your
company this morning an 11th hour
intervention but a home secretary
determined to press on with our plan to
send asylum seekers to rwanda after the
first flight taking them there was
grounded so what next in this
controversial and very complicated
battle of legal wills i'll be asking the
working pension secretary therese coffey
also the shadow foreign secretary david
lammy will also be getting the view of
an international lawyer on whether or
not those flights will ever get off the
ground it is wednesday 15th of june
disappointed but not deterred the home
secretary hits back after the first
flight to deport asylum seekers to
rwanda is blocked by the european court
of human rights
i'm in the rwandan capital kugali as the
government here says it remains ready to
receive deported asylum seekers when
they arrive and it's no punishment to
come here
3d printed guns on britain's streets
australia's investigation into how
social media is playing a part in what
police worn is an emerging trend
climate crisis a warning that almost 200
000 coastal properties in england could
be lost to rising seas within 30 years
cancel flights to avoid chaos the
warning to airlines ahead of our summer
holidays will be asking what it means if
you're heading away
hungary for more goals england suffer
their biggest home defeat in almost a
century losing
four nil in the nation's league
also ahead on the programme
[Music]
as girls allowed announced plans to
raise money for breast cancer research
as a tribute to sarah harding we'll be
speaking to kimberly walsh about her
latest project
and a punt in the sun with temperatures
set to rise into the 30s in some parts
at the end of the week find out how you
can make a splash in the hot weather
[Music]
morning all
it was the image the home secretary
certainly did not want to see the first
flight taking asylum seekers to rwanda
grounded on the tarmac long after its
departure time with no hope of taking
off the european court of human rights
blocked the flight at the 11th hour in a
move the home secretary said surprised
her let's take you through the key
developments
the flight well it was supposed to take
off from an raf base in wiltshire at
half past 10 last night with seven
people on board
but the european court of human rights
intervened to block the deportation of
an iraqi man which has opened the door
to legal challenges from the other six
the home office then announced that the
flight had been cancelled just less than
half an hour before takeoff
and while all of this was happening sky
news counted around 260 people crossing
the channel yesterday
including children and a baby
well in response the home secretary
pretty patel said this
i have always said this policy will not
be easy to deliver and i'm disappointed
that legal challenge and last-minute
claims have meant today's flight was
unable to depart she continues
it is very surprising that the european
court of human rights has intervened
despite earlier success in our domestic
courts
these repeated legal barriers are
similar to those we experience with
other removals flights and many of those
removed from this flight will be placed
on the next
we will not be deterred from doing the
right thing and delivering our plans to
control our nation's borders our legal
team are reviewing every decision made
on this flight and
preparation for the next flight begins
now
uh well the first group of depart
deported asylum seekers was meant to
arrive in the rwandan capital this
morning let's head to kigali where we'll
find skies at shingi maruriki good to
see you this morning so first fight as
many people predicted remained on the
tarmac question now is will the second
one make it
yeah and that is a good question neil
the rwandan government have reacted to
the news in a really similar fashion to
the uk government saying that they won't
be deterred and that they stand ready to
receive asylum seekers when they arrive
they would have been arriving here at
this hostel the hope guest house just as
we're speaking potentially but that's
not happening they were confident here
that they'll be ready to receive the
asylum seekers all the rooms were made
ready and laid out for their arrival and
yesterday we heard from the random
government who are saying that they're
ready to welcome people and they're
addressing so many other questions we
had from the human rights concerns
around the plan to the condemnation from
the church of england i asked about the
distress that coming here could have
caused the people scheduled to be on
that flight and in response they said to
me that it is not a punishment to come
here they still stand ready to receive
asylum seekers
shingi many thanks
uh well as you can see and i'm pleased
to say we're joined now by the working
pension secretary's coffee lovely to see
you this morning and
and i understand that rwanda is away
from your brief which we will be
spending a few minutes on but we must
start with rwanda i mean
who could have guessed that the first
flight to romanda would would not have
taken off but frankly pretty much
everyone bar the government so what
happens now
well the government has expected a lot
of legal challenges and we went through
the british courts who gave the go-ahead
for this flight to happen uh despite the
challenges that happened so i think you
know frankly the government is
disappointed in decision i've never
known such a quick decision made by
somebody the echr on this uh on on on
trying to intervene and i think the
public will be surprised we have
european judges overruling um british
judges but nevertheless uh i know the
home office is already getting ready for
the next flight and uh you know we will
continue to prepare and uh try and
overturn any future legal challenges as
well do you think that the amount of
money that we will have spent on on this
flight of flight which didn't take off
which will undoubtedly run into the six
figures it must run into the six figures
do you still maintain that this was
money well spent
well i know that we spend millions of
pounds a day on a broken asylum system
what i do know is that the priority for
the government is to make sure that safe
legal routes are prioritized and that we
try and do whatever we can through
deterring illegal unsafe routes because
the only people that profit are the
smugglers who frankly push people out
into boats and don't care if they arrive
or not so when will we get this next
flight when when are we anticipating
seeing perhaps a repeat of the scenes we
saw yesterday well it's for the home
office to uh focus on their operational
matters i'm not sure it's something i
particularly want to broadcast uh but
nevertheless preparations are underway
and i'm confident that the home
secretary pretty will be working with
her team uh to take the next steps that
are appropriate days are weeks i mean
you can give us a rough ballpark surely
i'm not going to get into operational uh
disclosures just in terms of of the the
embarrassment and it clearly is an
embarrassment for the government we
began the week with 130 packs supposed
to be on this flight we went down to
seven and now no one has been able to
leave again i reiterate this point given
that everyone apart from the government
could see this coming
do you still maintain that this was
value for money i do maintain its value
for money and anything we can do to
deter people uh binga put in the hands
of people smugglers is efforts that are
well deserved in terms of making sure
that we try and stop that and get people
towards safe legal routes you know this
is an unsafe thing to be doing to
pushing people out into the channel um
we know that's the case we know that's a
case of traffickers actually in all
parts of the world but nevertheless uh
this got through british courts uh
through the legal challenges and i'd say
we're surprised and disappointed that
the european judges have overturned that
i mean it is there you mentioned
deterrence i mean is there any evidence
that this has yet had any kind of
deterrent effect i mean figures very we
ourselves counted and you can see the
pictures there are 260 people coming
over the channel yesterday will probably
have been significantly more than that
clearly the prospect of being deported
to rwanda it's not having a deterred
effect
well i do believe that we will start to
see that as flights start to take off
the
government is resolved to making sure
that we do whatever we can to stop
illegal unsafe routes of immigration
into this country and that's why we'll
continue to make every effort we can
what are the safe routes well there are
a number of safe routes where people not
only through talent but also through
working with un in different parts of
the country so that's it it's basically
unless unless you can find unless you
can find a u.n representative to assist
you getting to this country or you
qualify under the point scheme you can't
claim asylum in this country well the
point is that uh when people do come
into the country legally of course they
can claim asylum when they are again i'm
asking how do you get into the country
legally if you're coming here to seek
asylum and you don't have permission to
enter you'll be aware there are a number
of countries that people are already in
where they can apply for asylum i'm not
asking about them i'm asking about you
and i'm telling i'm saying to you about
in terms of the different things that we
have done look we have a track record as
a country of offering places of refuge
and asylum to people from around the
world you know we've already undertaken
that significantly most recently with
the afghan resettlement scheme but also
things like with hong kong and british
nationals overseas there so there's a
number of routes that we have already
taken which are safe legal and we will
continue to stand by that track record
but do whatever we can to deter the
unsafe illegal routes of trying to get
into this country but still and again i
i hate to label this point the majority
of people who come across in small boats
are successful in their asylum claims
here under your scheme anyone who
arrives here illegally could could risk
being sent to to rwanda i don't know how
you square that circle
well because we're trying to stop
illegal unsafe routes and it is the
unsafe routes the routes that are legal
and we are having this perfectly
sensible partnership with rwanda i mean
the commonwealth heads the government
will be meeting there i think next week
uh this is not like it's uh some country
uh that isn't a modern democracy this is
about a partnership which was
established by the home secretary and
it's one that we believe is a good way
to proceed with this unsafe illegal
roots com people being put at risk in
order to get into this country i mean i
have heard one being characterized in
this way at the same time until at least
very relatively recently if it's not the
case this morning the fcdo were warning
against gay britons traveling to rwanda
so i'm not entirely certain that
everyone is sanguine with it but but
just in terms of how you proceed from
all of this clearly this government has
an issue with the european convention on
human rights and indeed the european
court on human rights asked about
withdrawing from both the prime minister
said it may very well be necessary to
change law i mean would you would you
really countenance withdrawing ourselves
from the convention that was set up
after the atrocities of the second world
war
well i think that we have never uh put
that as far as i'm aware in our
manifesto in in ill certainly the 29th
the prime minister seeing it yesterday
but i think it's just a as we have done
before where we've gone into court with
the echr a number of issues and
judgments have uh been made in favor of
the government you know we are a
law-abiding government and i'm very uh
i'm absolutely sure that frankly we will
get to any future discussions about that
but right now i'm not aware of any
decisions
or hints even about that the most
important thing is that we tackle this
issue right now we'll go back i'm sure
to the echr to challenge this initial
ruling and uh because as i say british
judges uh have made the decision um said
that these flights could go ahead and i
still think that's the best thing that
can happen so i i could i could get this
government complaining about european
convention about the european convention
and indeed echr oversight of our legal
system if this was just a legacy
document that we signed up to in 1950
but the fact of the matter is back when
you were drafting the political
declaration that that sorted out our
relationship between the uk and the
european union you put the convention on
human rights at the very heart of it and
here is the political declaration here
on page two of it the future
relationship between uk and eu should
incorporate the uk's continuing
commitment to respect the framework of
the european convention on human rights
it goes far further than that later on
in the document
i'm not really sure the point you're
making um
the 2019 manufacturer
the idea that you're maintaining that it
is an unforeseen consequence of giving
the european court oversight of our
legal system that the european court
exercises its oversight of our legal
system you signed up to it three years
ago in fact you said it should be under
the
rate
the parties the uk and the eu agree that
the scale and scope of future
arrangements should be underpinned by
long-standing commitments exactly to the
fundamental rights of individuals
including continued adherence and giving
effect to the echr but you can't
complain about something you yourself
signed up to no i'm not complaining in
the slightest our own british judges are
bound by ec the convention on human
rights that's why i think we were
surprised the chr
as i say the quickest decision i've ever
experienced as a minister made the
decision uh last night without him
without it it's a different uh approach
that's taken that's why my home office
colleagues and the home secretary will
be taking steps to look into the impact
of that nevertheless it british judges
made that decision made that ruling and
that's why we will be preparing for the
next flight uh but i think the whole
echr is just a surprise and a
disappointment as i say
where we are
if the echr has oversight of our legal
system i just don't get it no
it's a different situation it's a
specific thing about human rights it's a
surprise at the decision that they
reached and that's why our lawyers in
the home office will be continuing to
work on that and it's why our home
office will be continuing to prepare for
their next flights what level of
confidence do you have then that the
next flight will unlike yesterday take
off i'm highly confident uh you know
this decision was made a rapid pace uh
yesterday and as a consequence you know
it's right that the government continues
to try and make sure that we deter
unsafe illegal routes of asylum um sorry
people trying to enter the country
because the only people that benefit are
unscrupulous people traffickers often
trying to put people into modern slavery
as well so there's a number of different
things there uh but of course at the
same time uh we also want to make sure
that we continue to focus on the rest
the government as we are trying to do
today uh as we're introducing
legislation into parliament to help us
be able to process and make those
payments uh to help nearly eight million
households with the cost of living let's
talk indeed about the cost of living
it's it that is on your brief today and
we now have a timetable for for the
payment of the the 650 pounds just give
us a bit of detail on that when can
people expect to get that much needed
assistance so in terms of people who all
have already had 150 pounds or the
majority i think it's about 80 percent
of households will have already had 150
pounds of council tax rebate uh what
they'll be seeing through the payments
is next month they'll be getting half of
the 650 pound payment those people on uh
benefits uh indeed although people on
tax credits have to wait a little bit
longer because we don't want to
duplicate payments and then we'll be
making more payments later in the year
so that's people not only the second
half of the 650 pounds but also
pensioners will get an extra 300 pounds
alongside their winter fuel payment and
people with disabilities will get 150
pound payment as well can we talk then
just just briefly about about benefits
and i know that you're up in front of
the working pensions committee next week
but when you're in front of the liaison
committee you were asked whether or not
this government would look at you know
some kind of general uplift in terms of
benefits in terms of of legacy payments
i mean you said you'd go away and have a
look at it and see if it could be done
in a in a cost neutral way
is this something the government is
looking at but some form of increase to
the benefit system before i think it's
april next year when when when the next
kind of a when it would next be looked
at
so i'm looking and i haven't appeared in
front of the liaison committee so maybe
one of maybe somebody else has
i mean we have look carefully this is
the way through the legislation we're
doing today to give us the powers to
make these payments uh we're doing it at
pace so people will get money uh next
month at the same time about 70 percent
of working families will benefit from
the uplift in the national insurance
threshold
which on average i think will save
families an extra 350 pounds so i think
it's not a case of looking at rates of
individual benefits but by using these
interventions for the one-off payments
is something that we are mobilizing as
quickly as we can totally and and i get
that there are a lot of other ways in
which this government is trying to help
but why is it we obviously we understand
that since we lost that 20 pounds up
left to universal credit you know in in
real terms you know benefits are the
lowest for some estimate but for 30
years
why is this government so reticent to
look at just a general across the board
rise to that one universal payment that
was meant to simplify the benefit system
well we did um do an uplift because i do
i do an upgrading every year well it
rose and we use the
inflation rate uh that was the index
we've always used but of course my
department is really focused as well on
those people who can work to get them
into work and we have seen a record
number of people uh getting into work in
the last few months or sorry very high
hundreds of thousands of people and at
the same time we have um 1.3 million
vacancies and we are trying to do what
we can to help
uh people get into work because that is
definitely the best way of course to
boost somebody's income we will see you
at the working pensions committee next
week and we hope to see in the studio
soon thanks very much thank you now
let's have a very quick look at the
papers shall we uh starting with the
metro um their headline there
rwandan air force i think you can work
out the story that they're talking about
meanwhile the daily mail focuses on how
the flight was blocked at the 11th hour
uh by the echr
the times adds to the story it says that
the court's really has left britain on a
collision course with european judges
the guardian describes the decision as
throwing
the government's plans into chaos
the telegraph has the blocked flight as
their lead as well they also report a uk
government minister telling scotland's
first minister
she may have to wait until 2039 for
another independence referendum under
her mr sturgeon felt about that one
rwanda certainly uh to feature in
pmq's boris johnson and secure star
going head to head from midday today you
can of course watch that live
now almost 200 000 homes are at risk of
being lost in the next 30 years because
of flooding let's speak to our
correspondent madeleine radcliffe who's
in one of the coastal regions
potentially at risk at madeleine i hope
you're not standing too close to the
edge just explain exactly what the issue
is where you are
good morning yes it might be hard to
imagine on a sunny bright day like this
but towns like ader which is where i am
on the south coast in england
could be lost swallowed by the sea in
fact in 30 years time that's the
report's warning that places uh like
this uh town um shawrom on sea that's
the the clue is in the name and you can
see it really is built at sea level all
that protects it from the waves are this
this big shingle beach and the groins
and
the warning is 200 000 how homes and
businesses like those here could be lost
as sea levels rise that's a great deal
more than previously thought the real
the real reason is these towns think
that up until now the plan has been to
hold the line with defenses which exist
these big groins on the beach the banks
of sand that won't work as sea levels
rise by up to 35 centimeters by 2050 now
the report authors say they're not
trying to scare monger they just want to
start a really honest urgent discussion
about how we deal with the challenge of
rising sea levels
madeleine thanks very much absolutely
stunning down there
in the united states more than 10 000
people have been evacuated from
yellowstone national park because of
flooding
uh days of rain and rapid snowmelt
washed away cabins and knocked out power
lines goodness look at that no one was
killed or injured officials warn however
the park could stay closed for up to a
week i can certainly understand why
plenty coming up on the show this
morning i'll be speaking to the tribal
writer simon calder after airline and
aviation bodies were questioned by mps
about the travel chaos during the
halftime
running on empty i'll be speaking to a
taxi driver about the impact of
skyrocketing fuel prices on the industry
and we'll have the latest petrol price
for you at around half past night
[Music]
all right thomas come here
[Music]
one two three go
[Music]
wow
i'm going to be joined by renowned
beatboxer sk [ __ ] to talk about a
brand new show raising awareness for the
fight against suicide
also making headlines today women with
the so-called angelina jolie gene could
be closely monitored for their breast
cancer risk and potentially avoid
drastic surgery according to research
experts hope those with the bracha gene
may also be targeted with a drug to slow
down the risk of developing cancer
police in brazil have arrested a second
man in connection with the disappearance
of british journalist don don phillips
and indigenous expert bruno pereira the
men were last seen in the amazon
rainforest in western brazil 10 days ago
england's footballers suffered their
worst home defeat since 1928 after they
were thrashed four nil by hungary in the
nation's league last night gareth
southgate's men were booed off
after a second defeat to hungary in 10
days defender john stones was also sent
off the three lines well they've not won
in four games and they next face italy
and germany in september before heading
to the world cup in qatar
good luck lads
now the wealthy warm weather has
apparently prompted people working from
home to look for mouse jigglers to trick
their bosses that they are at their
computers at the jigglers they keep the
cursor moving so it makes like the pc is
constantly active more on that story
later on
now a sky news investigation has found
that 3d printed guns pose a growing
danger on british streets police have
described the threat from homemade
weapons as an emerging trend with their
use appearing to be particularly
prevalent among far-right groups sanya
burgess has this exclusive report on how
social media is playing a part
for this 3d printed gun
are easily found online
while recent mass shootings such as the
uvaldi school attack have reignited
debate over gun laws in the u.s
a mostly american online community has
sprung up
making designs
and reviewing their creations
we got a special project
it is the bubble gun
sky news found these influencers have
thousands of followers on social media
and it can take as little as three
clicks to go from a site like youtube to
a hosting website
to downloading gun files for free
one popular printable firearm the fgc 9
has more than 70 000 hits on its
download page
so this firearm is an example of the fgc
9. this was recovered in september 2021
from a borough in northeast london
since 2018 the metropolitan police have
recovered four partially constructed 3d
printed guns which are illegal in the uk
sky news has been given exclusive access
to the force's work on tackling 3d
printed guns which includes researching
and printing their own firearms we're
training our staff to look out for guns
that aren't conventional it could be
brightly coloured could look like a toy
it's an emerging trend and one that our
staff are aware of
building one of these firearms in the uk
is difficult they tend to need some
metal pieces
a printed version of this glock would
require springs pins the barrel and
other metal parts
it's not so straightforward to
a 3d printer gun you need all of the
correct components you need the right
designs you need to assemble it
correctly you need to test it with
ammunition which in the uk is not so
easy to come by
so do those putting the files online
feel responsible for who tries to use
them we have no interest in controlling
any other human beings that's quite
antithetical to our cause our only
interest
is the freedom of human beings to
protect themselves
in response to our story twitter said
keeping people safe on twitter is a top
priority for us
the account sky news shared have been
permanently suspended
instagram and youtube have removed
accounts which broke their policies
which forbid content intended to
instruct users on how to construct 3d
printed guns
sonya burgess sky news
parts of the uk could experience
something of a heat wave this week with
temperatures in some areas expected to
reach 34 degrees by friday at the met
office where they've issued a level two
heat health alert for large parts of
southern and central england with a
level one alert for the north keep an
eye on your neighbors um time to have a
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we're in for a mostly fine few days
turning hotter as well although there
will be outbreaks of rain in the cooler
northwest the southeast though could see
34 degrees by friday uh currently most
places fine and mild any early fog in
the southwest lifting but guess what
the far north has some patchy rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
red light green light remember that uh
netflix has announced it's bringing its
mega hits series squid game to life
with a new reality competition series uh
the korean drama series became the
streaming giant's biggest tv show ever
last year fans will now be able to apply
for squid game the challenge which will
see 456 real players enter the game in
pursuit of a prize of 4.56 million
dollars or 3.7 million pounds netflix
claims the show will host the largest
cast and cash pot prize in reality tv
history i suspect rather more might
survive that than the drama
uh k-pop sensation bts no me neither
they've announced that they're taking a
break
[Music]
the bands have announced that they're
taking a temporary pause in order to
pursue solo projects of which they'll
clearly be quite a few they're said to
be worth three and a half billion
dollars to the south korean economy
every year
however the news of their break wiped
1.47 sorry 1.7 billion dollars off the
value of their management company
remarkable uh coming up after the break
uh with russian forces now controlling
around 80 percent of the key city of
savannah donetsk we'll be hitting
analysis on the situation in ukraine
from the u.s army's former special
adviser mark voygar
[Music]
welcome back quick reminder as to our
top stories and the home secretary says
she's disappointed but not deterred
after the first flight to deport asylum
seekers to rwanda is blocked by the
european court of human rights
scania's investigation has found 3d
printed guns are posing a growing danger
on british streets
and a study has found that 200 000 homes
in england could be lost to flooding
within the next 30 years
[Music]
at just under half an hour ago the
working pension secretary therese coffey
told me the government is preparing to
challenge at the ruling blocking that
first rwanda deportation flight from
taking off
well the government has expected a lot
of legal challenges and we went through
the british courts who gave the go-ahead
for this flight to happen uh despite the
challenges that happened so i think you
know frankly the government is
disappointed in decision i've never
known such a quick decision made by
somebody the echr on this uh on on on
trying to intervene and i think the
public will be surprised we have
european judges overruling um uh british
judges but nevertheless uh i know the
home office is already getting ready for
the next flight just in terms of of the
the embarrassment and it clearly is an
embarrassment for the government we
began the week with 130 packs supposed
to be on this flight we went down to
seven and now no one has been able to
leave again i reiterate this point given
that everyone apart from the government
could see this coming
do you still maintain that this was
valued for money i do maintain its value
for money and anything we can do to
deter people uh bingo put in the hands
of people smugglers is efforts that well
deserved in terms of making sure that we
try and stop that and get people towards
safe legal routes what level of
confidence do you have then that the
next flight will unlike yesterday take
off i'm highly confident uh you know
this decision was made at a rapid pace
uh yesterday and uh as a consequence you
know it's right that the government
continues to try and make sure that we
deter
unsafe illegal routes of asylum sorry
people trying to enter the country
because the only people that benefit are
unscrupulous people traffickers often
trying to put people into modern slavery
as well so
our political correspondent ali
fortescue is once again in the studio
and and therese coffee expressing almost
the same level of confidence about the
second flight taking off as the liz
trust did yesterday about the first
flight yeah that's right i think um the
there have been various moods in the
home office over the last couple of days
i certainly pessimism two days ago
yesterday i think there was real
optimism that flight was going to go and
as you heard from trees coffee she says
that they're getting ready for the next
flight she said she's very confident the
next flight will go um but legally that
is going to be challenging and it could
come to a point where we're waiting till
july which i suppose isn't a long way
off when we have um this judicial review
it's the first challenge of the legality
of the policy exactly so that's the
moment when this is really going to be
sort of scrutinized and then you might
get a sense of whether this will
actually get the go-ahead um but i think
what was also from her was when you were
asking her about the hints yesterday
that the the prime minister could pull
the country out of the convention on
human rights it clearly would be a bit
significant moment she said not aware of
any decision or hints even about that
but she did say um that she thinks it's
likely that initial ruling from the echr
will be challenged no hints apart from
the prime minister saying that he was
looking at it ali for now thanks very
much
well those asylum seekers who were meant
to be flying to the east african country
were being held at a detention center
near heath row airport uh mario aurora
is there for us this morning and married
but we don't really know do we whether
or not those individuals who were
supposed to be on the flight last night
are now back there but certainly
there'll be plenty of others in that
building who may well be
scheduled to go on the second flight
[Music]
exactly neil we don't know we do know
that those asylum seekers originally on
that plane yesterday were here in this
immigration center uh center ahead of
their flight at from wheelchair you
don't know if they've been returned here
or not but as you say uh it's very very
likely that other asylum seekers in this
immigration centre behind me
will potentially be lined up for uh
flights to rwanda now originally there
was supposed to be about 130
migrants lined up for that flight uh set
to head off yesterday that then by yet
by the end of uh kind of yesterday went
down to seven uh so not the best look
for the government and then eventually
to zero now uh essentially those appeals
went to the wire
really really really close to the time
of takeoff those legal appeals came in
the european uh court of human rights
not convinced that essentially if those
asylum seekers were sent to rwanda and
needed to be returned if the policy was
found to be unlawful that that would
actually happen and therefore they uh
granted that injunction and the flight
was cancelled so we'll have to wait and
see whether those asylum seekers have
been returned to this immigration center
or perhaps a different one in a another
part of the country
maddie for now thank you very much
indeed
uh well it was of course a last-minute
ruling from the european court of human
rights that led to last night's flight
to rwanda being cancelled within half an
hour of takeoff but what does the court
do and on
what basis well it was set up by the
council of europe in 1959 to uphold
human rights and democracy on the
continent not related to the eu
now the court well it's made up of 47
elected judges one from each member
states they judge in cases in relation
to the european convention on human
rights
the court's judgments are
binding so countries must comply with
them
in the uk the main piece of legislation
on human rights is the 1998 human rights
act that means the rights and guarantees
from the european convention apply to uk
law replacing the hra was a conservative
manifesto pledge
in 2019
uh let's speak to someone who knows an
awful lot more about these matters than
i do the legal commentator joshua
rosenberg joshua very good morning to
you good morning neil
um so what happens next walk us through
the process i was speaking to the
working pension secretary to raise
coffee this morning uh who suggested
that they will be making preparations to
get a second flight on its way soon but
with this decision from the echr what
does it actually mean
certainly the human rights court in
strasbourg has said that the uk
government shouldn't do anything until
after the domestic proceedings are over
in other words a challenge scheduled to
be heard in the high court in london
next month and they've said that
the uk government should wait until
that's over perhaps until any appeals
against that decision are over and the
uk government is signed up to the human
rights convention as you've said and is
respecting that request from the judges
at the european court in strasbourg so
the question for the government
is when it chooses to schedule this
flight if it were to schedule it next
week then obviously it would be in
difficulties because this isn't going to
be resolved by the courts until next
month
but if it is uh willing to
wait until there's at least a decision
from the high court which i think we
would get by the end of july
it could of course be an appeal after
that then uh perhaps that would be
sufficient to comply with the court it
can also go back to the human rights
court and ask the court to
lift these
temporary measures these interim
measures that the court has effectively
imposed on the uk government uh once the
matter has been resolved by the courts
in london
on what basis joshua did the echr
stop this flight albeit potentially
temporarily
it said it had regard to concerns from
the united nations high commissioner for
refugees that asylum seekers transferred
from the uk to rwanda would not have
access to access to fair and efficient
procedures for deciding their refugee
status
it also looked at what the high court
said last week the question was whether
rwanda uh being a safe front
came back straight to my face joshua
sorry we lost you just for a second so
if we can just to try and try and pick
up again about two sentences ago if you
could yes okay and what the court said
last night was it had looked at
information
from the united nations high
commissioner for refugees that asylum
seekers transferred to rwanda would not
have access to fair and efficient
procedures for deciding their refugee
status there was a question raised by
the high court in london
as to whether the decision to treat
rwanda as a safe third country was
irrational or based on insufficient
inquiries that was something the high
court said gave rise to serious tribal
issues something it wants to resolve it
also took account of the fact that once
these asylum seekers returned to rwanda
the european court would have no
jurisdiction because of course rwanda is
not bound by the european convention on
human rights and in the absence of any
legally enforceable mechanism for
returning the individual particular
iraqi who brought this case to the uk
the court decided to grant this interim
measure to prevent his removal until the
domestic courts the uk courts had the
opportunity to consider those issues
just in terms of of what we've been
hearing from the government this morning
and indeed last night pretty patel
said that she was she was disappointed
and surprised
in the intervention by the echr
disappointed i can understand should she
have been desperately surprised though
she must have known that
the lawyers representing these asylum
seekers would go to court indeed the
government made it very clear it was
expecting legal challenges she would not
have known whether an order would be
issued by the high court by the court of
appeal by the supreme court or indeed by
the human rights court she might have
been surprised at how quickly the human
rights court was able to hear this given
that the supreme court uh turned down
the appeal by uh these asylum seekers
this one in particular uh just before
lunch yesterday about the human rights
court like all courts will move quickly
when it has to and to be fair to the
courts the deadline was set not by the
courts but by the government the
government announced when this plane was
going to take off the courts knew that
they had to move quickly they were able
to move quickly courts can move quickly
when they need to we know about delays
in their courts but when it's urgent
they can move quickly that's what
happened and uh given that the number of
people who was who were going to be
transferred to rwanda was dwindling uh
yesterday and in the days preceding it
down to a handful uh i don't think the
government could have been that
surprised uh that uh in the end uh there
were applications made on behalf of all
of them which were successful
joshua rosenberg thanks so much for your
time
uh let's turn
to ukraine now shall we and the battle
for the key eastern city of several
donetsk raging on a local official has
said that russian forces now control 80
of the city uh president vladimir
zelinsky has described ukrainian losses
as painful uh we're joined now by a
regular contributor to the program the
former special adviser to the u.s army
in europe mark voyager mark lovely to
see you this morning um
give us your take on on what we are
seeing in severo donetsk at the moment
is it now game over for the ukrainians
in that city
good morning thank you for having me
again
the fierce fighting in sivir donetsk
clearly demonstrates that the russian
military leadership has decided is
actually determined to capture the city
at all costs
uh reportedly uh there was a june 10
deadline that was set by putin and now
this date has uh has passed and gone
obviously the commander of the russian
forces john vornick of the so-called
butcher of syria has has been unable to
do it so
by the deadline and therefore um the
russians now are doubling
down on trying to capture the city
unfortunately um as you uh mentioned
most of the city has been destroyed
already
and in a way civil donetsk is about to
repeat the fate of mariopol only on a
smaller scale
effectively any city that resists the
russian advances is uh raised to the
ground
the um uh russians as i said are used
will use any any uh forces that they
could muster um they effectively use
soldiers as cannon fodder
trying to prevail over the ukrainian
defenders the ukrainians cannot afford
to lose soldiers and equipment at that
rate
and i fear that at some point in order
to evade the so-called encirclement
so that the russians
would capture the ukrainian forces in a
pocket it would happen in 2014-2015
on two occasions the ukrainians might be
forced to withdraw to a more defensible
positions uh to the west uh of the city
and hold some of the critical
um junctions and the routes that
also the defend
uh cities like kramatur slaviansk
and other areas
effectively now the ukraines are
defending on three sides and it's a um
it's a really serious situation the good
news is that into the south in her son
the aquarium counter offensive is is
gaining ground which shows us that the
russians uh if the russian military
cannot sustain two operations at the
same time
and if
enough aid military aid they may be able
to turn the tide in some of those areas
mark i i suppose then the question is
those countries like the united kingdom
which are minded to help the ukrainians
in their battle with with russia what
help can they be particularly in that
part of the country where you know
several donetsk you know mario paul
where they are simply raising
square miles of the country completely
to the ground
yes this is a fact uh unfortunately but
for the ukrainians to
regain their territories
they cannot they cannot afford to strike
uh those territories uh with um
um soviet and russian-made uh equipment
they need the precision strike
capabilities that is the multiple launch
uh rocket systems uh more drones that
will allow them to pinpoint where the
russian forces are
i mean the ukrainian territory has been
sufficiently destroyed as it is
ukraine cannot afford to actually
reconquer
uh those lands uh by discriminate fire
the way the russians are doing and
therefore um any
additional high precision weapons which
is exactly what the aquarium leadership
has requested
uh must be met with the understanding of
this uh
the terrible predicament the ukrainians
are fighting on their own territory
having to reclaim important industrial
nodes and areas still populated by tens
of thousands of ukrainian citizens um
that are caught in the mid in between
the hammer and the anvil
so the west must give more precision
strike uh platforms to the ukrainians
to begin with
mark we will no doubt again uh speak
again very very soon indeed for now
thanks very much your time
thank you
now as airlines are warned to cancel
upcoming flights to avoid potential
travel chaos this summer i'll be
speaking once again to the independence
travel editor about the possible impact
on passengers
[Music]
welcome back uk airlines have been
warned to cancel flights they can't
sustain this summer to avoid causing
travel chaos the warning comes after
tens of thousands of holidaymakers were
affected by delays and cancellations
last month which they blamed on staff
shortages joining us now the
independence travel editor simon calder
simon lovely to see you this morning um
i unfortunately was unable to watch the
committee hearing uh committee hearings
yesterday um as i was asleep frankly so
tell us what we heard from from the
airlines well was there an awful lot of
contrition on display by any chance
well there was um depending which
airline you talked to so tui uh the
biggest holiday company in the uk which
obviously also um has an airline of its
own then you will recall the terrible
scenes we saw on sky news at the start
of the main end of may bank holiday uh
with all sorts of people finding out
quite often on the plane that their
holiday had been cancelled it was in the
words of the uh boss of tui dave burling
he said it was unacceptable and we also
heard from british airways that they are
cancelling a lot of flights because they
don't have enough uh resources but they
stopped short of um confirming that this
was due to the ten thousand or so people
they uh let go during the uh covid
pandemic and easyget said well yeah we
are cancelling some flights but we're
doing our best what's happened overnight
is that the department for transport
here in central london and the civil
aviation authority have written to the
airlines with a very stern warning and a
lot of people will be saying well thank
goodness at last because uh this could
have been sent this uh strongly worded
letter from the director general of
aviation here at the dft and also the uh
chief executive of the caa it says we
cannot have any more of these
unacceptable scenes and you are going to
have to help us quote de-risk the summer
to make sure that your flying programs
are deliverable
now that so we've had so sorry simon so
we've had both so we've had both the
department for transport tui and
presumably others saying this was
unacceptable i mean i suppose the
question is was it avoidable however
uh well it was uh to use that terrible
cliche a perfect storm of course what we
have seen is that um since the end of
the well at the end of the kobe pandemic
the end of the travel restrictions um of
course uh well you the transport
secretary grant shouts himself said
hooray we can all go on holiday as we
used to which is um terrific except it's
not quite true because the airlines
having been crushed by the travel
restrictions and the kovic pandemic
are
clearly were not in sufficient state to
run the schedules they had proposed now
some of them are doing absolutely uh
fine um there was a big shout out from a
lot of people to uh ryanair and jet too
who've been running everything um pretty
much according to schedule the odd delay
here or there occasionally a
cancellation but british airways and
easyjet are cancelling flights uh in
extraordinary numbers so ba have
cancelled more than 100 shortfall
european and domestic flights today but
they cancelled those generally two or
three weeks ago and gave people plenty
of warning easyjet have cancelled over
40 flights to and from gatwick airport
today and uh they quite often only gave
people a few days and maybe in some
cases a few hours noticed and this
letter neil is aimed squarely at easyget
the part which says you've got to have a
deliverable uh schedule and that means
if you have an easyjet booking this
summer you shouldn't be amazed to get an
email saying oh you were booked on the
nine o'clock to malaga on the 7th of
august well that's now uh cancelled but
you can go at seven o'clock in the
morning or um one o'clock in the
afternoon there will be lots of that
happening i understand over the next few
days possibly the next week but most
people will still be able to get where
they need to be so do not panic and
don't take a refund they have to offer
you an alternative flight either on
their own airline or if they haven't got
space on the day they have to find you a
flight with somebody else
simon fantastic advice as always mine is
simply go and talk your tan up this week
just in case you don't get away that's
what i'm doing after i come off here
simon colder lovely to see you thanks
for being with us
ah let's quickly they'll take you
through the best pictures making the
morning's papers the times uh showing us
this beautiful shot of that june
superman the strawberryman as it passed
behind glastonbury tour on monday the
guardian ability gives us a few pictures
from a french photojournalist who
decided to feature one of senegal's most
prized commodities rams here they are
posing with their beloved owners and the
express shows as a wonderful fly past of
an raf merlin and two raf wildcats over
the national memorial arboretum marking
the 40th anniversary of the falklands
conflict
coming up after the break the working
pension secretary told me she's highly
confident the next flight to rwanda will
take off will it we'll get reaction from
labour next
[Music]